[Music]
[Music]
the cycle of this world i will not allow
it to perish with you
[Music]
i seek to destroy the irrational power
structure that shackles foodland
if the kingdom is ever to part ways with
our bloody past
this is the path we must walk
i have ambitions edelgard real wise
[Music]
will you sit around and wait for a
miracle
or will you help me seize control of my
fate
we shall fight
we shall survive and we shall win a
glorious future for foodland
but now that i know
i won't make the same mistake again
[Music]
revenge is not a thing you take for
someone else
you seek revenge to slake your rage and
heal your wounded heart
i know you are prepared to do whatever
that you must
hello everyone i'm shinya takahashi and
i'll be your guide for today's nintendo
direct
what you just saw was the trailer for
the fire emblem warriors three hopes
[Music]
we hope you look forward to a different
story set in the same universe as fire
emblem 3 houses
let's see the first batch of nintendo
switch headlines
the orange star nation needs you
[Music]
we've got more intel on the advanced
wars oneplus 2 reap bootcamp game
in the first campaign advance wars
you'll advise a colorful cast of
commanding officers and use their
abilities in vibrant turn-based battles
each commanding officer is now voiced
bringing even more charm to these
characters you're gonna get hurt i see
right through your plans another full
campaign awaits in advance wars 2 black
hole rising more commanding officers and
more diverse terrain can be leveraged
for additional tactical opportunities
like blasting through pipelines to cross
into enemy territory in both campaigns
you can fast forward gameplay and reset
your turns for a smoother tactical
experience
flex your strategic muscles outside of
both campaigns with additional modes
go for high scores in the war room
create and share custom maps in the
design room
or battle friends and frenemies in local
and online multiplayer
[Music]
advanced wars oneplus 2 reboot camp
marches onto the nintendo switch system
april 8th pre-orders are available now
on nintendoesha
[Music]
explore an infinite universe
in no man's sky
every star is the light of a distant sun
each orbited by planets teeming with
life
travel to planets of your choosing in
this infinite procedurally generated
universe
here you'll discover extraordinary lands
and creatures that have never been seen
before and may never be seen again
to survive
you must craft your own tools and even
your own place to live
in this living and breathing universe
trade convoys travel between stars
factions vie for territory
pirates hunt unwary travelers
and the authorities are ever watchful
your journey may be fraught with danger
and actions have consequences
traitor
fighter
explorer
how will you live in this universe
no man's sky lands on nintendo switch
this summer
um
right
[Music]
[Music]
mario striker's battle league
prepare for strike a five five-on-five
sport like soccer that's way heavy on
offense aim for goals by dribbling and
passing to teammates as well as by using
tackles
items
and crushing special shots
the main rule in this sport is to rule
the field
try to score more goals than your
opponents
there are two things to keep in mind
that'll help you with your strategies
first the gear you equip it changes not
only your appearance but also your stats
like speed strength and pass accuracy
customize as you see fit
second
the hyper strike
to activate this shot grab an orb when
it appears on the field
and charge it while your opponents are
distracted
hit the net and you'll score not one but
two goals
up to eight players four players on each
team can compete against each other on
one nintendo switch system
in addition to individual matches
online play will have an online club
mode
join an in-game club and compete for
placement in the rankings
up to 20 players can join a club so
create your own and invite friends and
family to play alongside you or join an
existing one owned by other players
try to become the world's tough club
with items
tackles
and hyper strikes
anything goes on this field
mario strikers battle league launches on
nintendo switch june 10th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
the latest iteration of the mario
strikers series is coming to nintendo
switch
we hope you're excited for this anything
goes battle soccer game
next please take a look at this
[Music]
[Music]
big be
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
right
[Music]
that was the trailer for the co-op mode
in the splatoon 3 game the next wave of
salmon run
a giant salmonid one that's never been
seen before was also spotted at the end
of the trailer will the inklings and
octolings ink or swim
splatoon 3 will launch this summer we
hope you'll look forward to future
updates
let's move on to more nintendo switch
headlines
[Music]
fonzer's at the ready
a full remake of the first front mission
game is storming onto nintendo switch
in this tactical rpg you'll pilot
weaponized machines called vonsers and
lead your battalion to victory
[Music]
gain the upper hand in battle by aiming
for enemy parts to destroy
mix and match various weapons and parts
to customize your vonser
uncover the great storyline of this
classic when front mission 1 remake
launches on nintendo switch this summer
and in the future the sequel front
mission 2 remake will also launch on
nintendo switch
[Music]
get set for a high octane disney and
pixar combat racer
from the creators of the asphalt series
comes rip roaring racing action across
disney and pixar inspired race tracks
race as a legendary roster of characters
on high-speed circus using each one's
special abilities to battle for victory
across the finish line
choose mickey mouse for symphonic speed
sully for monstrous power or mulan for
explosive maneuvers
each racer also possesses powerful
ultimate skills perfect for turning the
tables at the last second
disney speedstorm is a free-to-play game
with new seasons added regularly
bringing more exciting disney and pixar
characters
circuits carts and more
plus enjoy cross-platform play as well
as split screen and online multiplayer
modes
disney speed storm races onto nintendo
switch this summer
dive into these classic franchises on
nintendo switch
unleash the power of the force in this
classic star wars action adventure as
darth vader's secret apprentice you'll
use devastating force powers and
lightsaber combos as you hunt down jedi
masters on iconic planets
upgrade abilities like force grip and
force repulse then combine them for even
more destructive combos
use button controls or opt for motion
controls enhanced from the original wii
version
you can also dual locally with a friend
to determine who is the galaxy's most
powerful jedi
star wars the force unleashed launches
on nintendo switch april 20th pre-orders
begin today on nintendo eshop
the complete saga of legendary assassin
ezio auditore da frenze awaits in three
critically acclaimed assassins creed
games
explore renaissance italy and 16th
century constantinople interact with
historical figures and discover secrets
of the creed across three games two
bonus short films and dlc
plus take advantage of enhanced features
for the nintendo switch system on the go
including touchscreen controls hd rumble
and optimized on-screen display
assassin's creed the ezio collection
launches a nintendo switch february 17th
pilot mobile shoots in dynamic action
rpg battles
strange incidents called brakes are
occurring across the gundam universe
find out what's causing them and restore
the proper timeline you'll need three
mobile suits in battle
enhance each suit with parts to improve
their power you can also battle
alongside friends in online co-op
multiplayer sd gundam battle alliance
launches on nintendo switch this year
two worlds cross in the triumphant
return of this rpg classic
a remaster of the acclaimed rpg chrono
cross is coming to the nintendo switch
system
one fateful day the protagonist surge
wanders into an alternate world
though it somewhat resembles his
homeworld he finds that he no longer
exists here
how did this happen
what is this mysterious another world
travel back and forth between both
worlds to unravel the story
over 40 characters can join your party
depending on the choices you make the
allies who accompany you and the endings
that trigger will differ
a number of improvements have been made
to this remaster
like the ability to turn off enemy
encounters and a newly enhanced
soundtrack
plus radical dreamers originally
released on the citella view is included
experience the origins of chronocross in
this text-based adventure
chronocross the radical dreamers edition
dashes and slashes its way onto nintendo
switch april 7th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's kirby's latest unforgettable 3d
platforming adventure kirby and the
forgotten land
it all takes place in a mysterious world
with an unusual mix of nature and
civilization
to rescue the kidnapped waddle dees
kirby sets off on a new adventure
[Applause]
introducing
mouthful mode
inhale a car to zoom around
[Music]
[Applause]
a vending machine to attack with juice
cans
or become a piercing cone
with mouthful mode new actions will be
available for kirby depending on the
object he inhales
enjoy exploring with new moves different
from copy abilities
kirby can even weaponize a mouthful of
water like this
as kirby rescues waddle dees waddle
d-town will continue to grow and more
resources will become available
at waddle d's weapon shop familiar copy
abilities can be evolved
evolve copy abilities to expand kirby's
range of attacks
they'll also change kirby's appearance
and make him even more powerful
some copy abilities may have stronger
involved forms
[Music]
a new adventure awaits our pink puffball
[Music]
who are the beasts back
what are these enemies trying to do
[Music]
can kirby restore peace to this world
kirby and the forgotten land launches on
the nintendo switch system march 25th
pre-orders are available now on nintendo
eshop
that was kirby and the forgotten land
launching later next month
please look forward to its release
let's take a look at some more nintendo
switch headlines
nintendo director
konichiwa
notes
the show is coming to nintendo's switch
that means you could play modes like
road to the show and diamond dynasty on
your nintendo switch but that's not all
you can even play exhibition with a
single joy-con controller with
cross-progression you can also earn and
use content on any platform where mlb
the show 22 is available and take your
progress on the go with you on nintendo
switch have friends that play mlb the
show 22 online matches on other consoles
no need to worry you can invite them and
play online
[Music]
i knew you were a true two-way player
but this is ridiculous
sheesh
[Music]
you're gonna have your hands full of
games with these collections
three kingdom hearts collections are
almost here
from kingdom hearts to kingdom hearts 3
and the remind dlc every entry is coming
to nintendo switch as cloud versions
that can be played while connected to
the internet
relive or get to know these heart-filled
adventures alongside sora donald goofy
and more for the first time in tv
tabletop or handheld mode
kingdom hearts intragram masterpiece for
cloud containing all three game
collections soars onto nintendo switch
tomorrow
each collection's cloud version will
also be individually available on
nintendo eshop
clinoa is coming to nintendo's witch
across dreamy side scrolling levels
you'll run jump and hover while firing
wind bullets to grab and throw enemies
use each level surroundings to your
advantage
[Music]
also clinoa 2 is included
take on these great adventures when
clinoa fantasy reverie series launches a
nintendo switch july 8th
we're so glad you're here
come here often
either way you're in for a puzzling
treat
in these award-winning games the portal
gun is your key to surviving
imprisonment in a mysterious lab
create portals and warp to other areas
to find
cake
still unconfirmed you can pass through
portals and so can cubes lasers and
robots with unnerving levels of
personality
the sequel adds in local online and
split screen multiplayer modes and that
part's no lie
neither is the sentient robot monitoring
your every move when portal companion
collection warps onto nintendo switch
this year
[Music]
a classic comes alive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
previously unreleased outside of japan
the rpg live alive makes its overseas
debut now in hd 2d multiple stories
featuring different protagonists and
time periods await the order in which
you tackle them is up to you pre-history
a tribesman comes of age in a world
without words
the wild west a wanderer with a bounty
on his head fights for his life
imperial china a kung fu master searches
for a worthy successor
twilight of edo japan as shinobi
undertakes an important secret mission
present day a martial artist strives to
become the strongest there ever was
the near future a youth with psychic
powers takes a stand against evil the
distant future a newly built robot is
swept up in a tragedy in space
what other stories are on the horizon
you will repay my loyalty
in death
live alive launches on nintendo switch
july 22nd
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
how was that
next up is this
it's a new iteration of the wii sports
series
[Music]
nintendo switch sports
please take a look
[Music]
here are the sports included in the
nintendo switch sports game
you might recognize these three from
past wii sports games
tennis
rally by gently swinging the joy-con
controller at the right time
[Music]
bowling
roll the ball straight ahead or give it
a little curve
and chambra
knock your opponent off the platform
while attacking and defending
plus three additional sports are joining
the lineup
[Music]
soccer
use a gigantic ball to make dynamic
plays
enjoy matches with joy-con controllers
to shoot and perform diving headers
by attaching a joy-con controller to the
leg strap accessory included with the
physical version of the game you can
play shootout mode with intuitive
kicking motions
badminton
control your shots left and right while
keeping the shuttlecock in the air
unleash powerful smash shots to gain the
upper hand
[Music]
finally volleyball
use a joy-con controller to serve
bump
set
and spike the ball
[Music]
the game supports local play with family
and friends on one nintendo switch
system as well as online play across all
sports
play against friends online
or opt for random matchmaking
the more you win the tougher the players
you'll face
[Music]
try taking on this challenge
[Music]
how was that since i'm already here i'd
like to show you some gameplay of one of
the newly added sports volleyball
mr takahashi
oh hello there everyone i'm yoshiaki
koizumi from nintendo
wow mr koizumi i can see you're ready to
play
all right i'll play some volleyball
online together with mr koizumi do you
have your wrist strap ready
yes of course
i've got plenty of space around me as
well
all right let's start we'll be including
some live commentary throughout our
match
all right oh we're doing this uh
volleyball a newly added sport in
nintendo switch sports
what can we expect today from the
takahashi koizumi team
it's koizumi to serve with takahashi up
front
we begin with koizumi serving
how will the opposing team react
takahashi makes the block
another one's coming
koizumi saves it let's set up in the air
and here comes the spike
the other team saves it and fights back
and they score
takahashi didn't quite get it in time
all right well it's okay it's okay the
game's not over
now the other team serves
koizumi receives it takashi sets it up
and koizubi spikes but it goes right
toward the opponent
here's another attack
now's their chance they get the ball
and with the setup from koizumi
takahashi scores
they got a point with that fierce spike
let's stop our match here after all we
were in the middle of a presentation
all right i'll be leaving now
that was an introduction to nintendo
switch sports
the game launches april 29th
we're planning a free update in the
summer that allows you to play soccer
matches with a joy-con controller and
the leg strap accessory you can use the
accessory to place shootout mode at
launch
in addition
we're also planning a second free update
this fall that lets you enjoy golf
[Music]
and now a request to everyone
to help ensure that you can all enjoy
playing online we'll be having an online
play test before the game launches to
evaluate various technical aspects
we definitely like to ask for your help
with this
the online playtest will only be
available for players with an active
nintendo switch online membership on the
dates shown on screen
for those of you interested please visit
the official nintendo website for more
details
thank you
that's all i have for now about nintendo
switch sports
i hope you're looking forward to this
game
let's see a few more nintendo switch
headings
get those taiko drumming skills ready
the latest taikano toxigen game is
coming to the nintendo switch system set
in omiko city the sacred town for taiko
drops you'll strive to become a taiko
master along with brand new character
kumokun
drum to dozens of poppin beats including
megalovania gurenge feel special and
racing into the night and that's not all
an orchestral version of the main theme
from the legend of zelda is included
that's 76 songs total
plus take advantage of a practice mode
to replay sections of songs as many
times as you'd like
new modes have also been added for
everyone to enjoy put on a live concert
with up to four players in donchian band
or face off against each other in great
drum toy war
[Music]
drum to your heart's content
when taiko no tatsujin rhythm festival
launches on nintendo switch this year
plus a paid in-game subscription service
that gives you access to over 500 songs
will be available at launch
[Music]
what's new with these nintendo switch
games
the brand new tactical rpg game triangle
strategy is almost here
the protagonist sarah noah and his
allies will be engulfed in the conflict
among three nations your choices and
conviction will determine their fate as
lord of house wolford i solemnly swear
an oath by which all future lords shall
be bound i will never turn my back on
the promise of a better world
a new demo playable to the end of
chapter 3 will be available on nintendo
eshop later today
save data from the demo can be
transferred to the full game once
purchased
more cuphead action awaits in the paid
dlc cuphead the delicious last course
here you'll explore a brand new inkwell
isle
defeat a bevy of new bosses with wild
personalities and even wilder attacks
the clever miss chalice is a new
playable character
take down fearsome foes with her double
jumps rolling dodges and more
cuphead the delicious last course
wallops its way onto nintendo switch
june 30th
[Music]
a free update is coming to the metroid
dread game
all it takes is one hit
even from this
getting hit even once causes a game over
in the brutal dread mode difficulty
can you face this new challenge
and for players new to the metroid
series take advantage of increased
recovery with the newly added rookie
mode difficulty
[Music]
this free update launches later today
[Music]
a second free update in april will add a
boss rush mode in which you'll battle
bosses continuously one at a time
[Music]
something's bound for nintendo switch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
earthbound
and earthbound beginnings will be added
to nintendo switch online later today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what did you think
here's some news from mario kart fans
many of you have been enjoying the mario
kart 8 deluxe game since its launch in
2017.
so
we've been working on remastering select
courses from across the mario kart
series and we'll be releasing them as
paid downloadable content
please take a look at this trailer
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
paid dlc courses will be coming to mario
kart 8 deluxe
this is the mario kart 8 deluxe booster
course pass
you may recognize some courses from past
mario kart games
eight courses will be released at a time
over six waves that's 48 additional
courses we plan on releasing by the end
of 2023
courses such as coconut mall
[Music]
chaco mountain
and tokyo blur will be included in the
first wave
of course you can play these courses
locally and online
[Music]
the first wave of the mario kart 8
deluxe booster course pass will launch
march 18th
pre-orders begin today a nintendo eshop
you can enjoy this dlc at no additional
cost with a nintendo switch online plus
expansion pack membership or purchase
the mario kart 8 deluxe booster course
pass on its own
[Music]
how was that
i hope you're looking forward to the
additional courses in mario kart 8
deluxe
this next segment will be our last
announcement
please take a look
[Music]
fighting in order to live
and living to fight
[Music]
that's the way of our world
ionios
tell me
what would possess you to side with them
we're fighting because there are enemies
to kill i refuse to believe you're him
i knew it i saw this coming you are
you're not enemies now fine for you
isn't it all that time you've got you
could try try to move forwards again how
can our lives be so snuffing little do
you they're not your friends anymore
they're his few
march
the land pierced by a great sword
it's the only way you're gonna defeat
the real enemy
whatever life is lost i won't let you
solder it all alone what could filling
up these flickering clocks in our eyes
it will never replace the predatory
block the flame clock it has to go
uroboros are bore this world they must
be erased without a trace
[Music]
the story of xenoblade chronicles 3 ties
together the futures of the worlds
depicted in xenoblade chronicles and
xenoblade chronicles 2 and it will
launch this september i hope you look
forward to it
that's all for today's nintendo direct
thank you for watching
[Music]
you